[Musik]
sie ist unbekümmert furchtlos
eigenwillig talentiert und geht eigene
wege lara gut hat eigenschaften die
erfolg versprechen mit 18 jahren hat sie
bereits einen steilen aufstieg hinter
sich aber sie kennt auch den jeden fall
[Musik]
am 27 september 2009 stürzt lara gut
beim training in saas fee ein harmloser
sturz so scheint es doch lara gut kugelt
sich die rechte hüfte aus
[Musik]
in chronik raus was los war die
steigenden erste verlässt sie denn
im spital einen pfleger naja ok offen
und sechs - was bedeutet das und machen
sie auch zwei monate pause auch
jetzt realisiert
denkt bin stöße und sie sind mit dem
männlicher und ein weiblicher
[Musik]
das nicht passiert ist da auch in der dr
kurt und seit jahren beste ist dass mir
sofort jährlich ob der effekt aber du
kannst es nicht so schlimm
[Musik]
ein jahr zuvor ebenfalls in saas fee
am frühen morgen schon dringen sich die
sommer skifahrer vor der talstation des
alpin express es ist kurz vor bad wie so
oft in den letzten jahren ist auch lara
gut mit ihrem vater pauli dabei die
beiden bereiten laras erste weltcup
saison vor
[Musik]
der 17-jährigen lara gut geht der ruf
eines wunderkindes voraus seit sie an
den schweizer meisterschaften 2007 eine
silbermedaille gewonnen hat sie war
damals nicht einmal 16 jährig
[Musik]
pauli gut ist mit seiner talentierten
tochter schon immer eigene wege gegangen
als lara sich anschickt den weltcup zu
erobern engagiert der mauro pini einen
kollegen aus seiner jugendzeit als
trainer seit lara zwei jahre alt war
hatte pauli gut praktisch jede freie
minute mit ihr auf den skis verbracht
er hatte für sie sogar einen eigenen ski
club gegründet als er mit ihrer
betreuung beim skiclub paolo nicht mehr
einverstanden war
[Applaus]
audi arbeitet als lehrer an der
gewerbeschule in lugano doch um lara
eine optimale sportliches umfeld bieten
zu können lässt er sich beurlauben er
gründet das team gut ein
familienunternehmen sozusagen und wird
klar als manager
es ist
ja der vorteil ist dass praktisch alle
tollitäten rolle die leute sind
auf lager konzentriert und das ist sehr
großer vorteil
aber das fällt dadurch ihrem berater
vergleich mit anderen frauen im schnitt
also wäre eine möglichkeit wenn du nur
drei athleten athletinnen
mit andere egal ich brauche einfach
mauro pini laras trainer ist ein
erfahrener mann in welt
gekommen
gegen die andere sprechen doch
spezieller mental stärker
seine
nationalität
ich finde das auch dem schnee wird
machen nicht bezahlt die andere
keinen speziellen aber zumindest einen
anderen weg lara gut absolviert das
sommertraining in der schweiz während
die kolleginnen des nationalteams nach
neuseeland fliegen
[Musik]
lara ist das nesthäkchen in einem von
männern dominierten team das programm
ist vollkommen auf sie ihre bedürfnisse
und ihre befindlichkeit ausgerichtet im
team gut dreht sich alles um lara
gleichaltrige kollegin freilich hat sie
nicht
wie viel jüngeren der athletin xi und
dann ab und zu
an der idee kam und an das training
braucht
zum team von lara gehört der servicemann
barnaba gräppi auch gräppi ist eine
fahrender mann grippe kennt sich aus mit
olympiasiegerinnen und weltmeisterinnen
und weiß was diese von anderen
unterscheidet denn er hat schon für
deborah compagnoni und isolde kosten
radies präpariert
was ich schon immer gesagt habe lara ist
eine der sensibelsten fahrerinnen die
ich je gehabt habe auch das gefühl für
die skis anbetrifft
man kann sie mit deborah compagnoni
vergleichen die auch sehr gute feedback
geben konnte friedberg sind sehr wichtig
für unsere arbeit wir brauchen
fahrerinnen die uns sagen können was an
einem ski nicht gut ist
es reicht nicht einfach zu sagen dieses
nicht gut wir müssen wissen was daran
nicht gut ist
für eine so junge athletin ist lara
bereits unheimlich weit ich denke sie
ist sogar eine der besten überhaupt
lara hatte einen jüngeren bruder jan den
fachleute ähnlich viel talenten absagen
wie lara
die familie wohnt in command oberhalb
von lugano
durch die beurlaubung ist pauli gut ein
großes finanzielles risiko eingegangen
er verzichtet zum einen auf ein
jahreseinkommen als lehrer vom sicher
hunderttausend franken
und zum anderen kostet ihn das
engagement für seine tochter noch einmal
300.000 franken viel geld
wasserträger kostet was
fast einig kosten sowie
das sind schon große
show aber eine webseite
sponsoren mir sehr gut unterstützt
dennoch für die eigenen kinder ein
solches risiko einzugehen ohne jede
erfahrung im sponsoring geschäft vor
dieser aufgabe hätten wo die meisten
kapituliert nur eben nicht nur lara auch
ihr vater ist anders als alle anderen
so zu die eine potenzielle sprungs oder
kommen und das ist auch und sogar
mal ein wenig
aber wenn
wenn du al arisch
wollen sie das potenzial hätten so gut
ist
rohstoffe
jetzt warten
und potenzial hat lara in der tat
rutschte bis 10
das gibt's ja gar nicht das geht es ja
gar nicht
das ist die verrückteste geschichte
seite schüler einen kommentar sie stellt
und sie wird weiter ihre
ersten weltcup abfahrt überhaupt wird
lara gut in st moritz trotz ihres
sturzes dritte sie ist keine 17 jahre
alt und wir lachen verzaubert eine ganze
nation
durch diesen dritten rang ist lara gut
über nacht zu einem begriff geworden
aus der schülerin die sich im
fernstudium auf die matura vorbereitet
ist eine hoffnungsträgerin für den
schweizer skisport geworden
alle reißen sich um lara alle wollen
etwas von ihr
in einem tag trifft
pause also beantwortet dass du endlich
ja aber eine lange braucht
schnelle und
lara ist keine person die sich ihrem
gegenüber offenbart eigenwillig fast
schon störrisch schützt sie sich vor der
neugierde der öffentlichkeit
das wichtigste
[Musik]
drei monate später führt laras weg
zurück nach st moritz an den ort ihres
internationalen durchbruchs sie ist im
weltcup ins schweizer nationalteam
integriert wohnt und trainiert mit den
anderen schweizerinnen
ihre resultate haben lara gut in den
mittelpunkt gerückt
und die anderen fahrerinnen registrieren
dies wohl
kümmern sich euro
man sieht es gibt da sicher ein wenig
aber das ist gut ich hoffe unsere
mädchen von und zeigen sie werden auch
in den medien seien trotz der
integration im nationalteam wird lara
gut auf und neben der piste auch jetzt
ausschließlich von mauro pini bedroht
[Applaus]
ich glaube schon da setzten ihre katzen
in der praxis sieht dies so aus während
sich acht betreuer fürs nationalteam
über die strecke verteilen und jeder
einen einzelnen abschnitt betreut
begleitete mauro pini lara gut vom start
bis ins ziel
richtig
ich glaube wir haben eine achtbare augen
auf der abfahrt und vielleicht könnten
geben nicht vergeben aber manchmal ich
besser wenn nur eine person spricht so
solange wir können zusammen gut mit
maurerarbeiten kassiert kurz
funktionieren die zusammenarbeit
funktioniert die betreuer ziehen an
einem strick
wie läuft das ist auch meine arbeit
sehr gut selbst zufrieden ich hoffe dass
die sind auch zufrieden mit uns ja auch
wirklich gute kooperation in welchen
punkten könnte ihr profitieren vom
whisky der struktur organisation wie die
arbeitsvorbereitung diese solche sache
und auch
[Musik]
technische
was sagen wir
wir haben viele diskussionen zwischen
uns und sehr interessant auch für mich
[Musik]
hotels last rheins oberhalb von sankt
moritz hier wohnen die schweizerinnen
während den renntagen im engadin
gemeinsam mit mauro pini verarbeitet
lara das training von diesem morgen am
computer
video-studium
system die schlüssel aus dass noch vor
dem tour in oder was machst du
das jetzt gemacht dann nicht gemacht
ich habe sonst mache
[Musik]
renntag es schneit und es ist windig
lara hat für den super g die nummer eins
gezogen bei diesen verhältnissen ist
dies alles andere als ein vorteil aber
lara gelingt das umzusetzen was sich am
abend vorher vorgenommen hat sie bleibt
fehlerlos uns ist so schnell wie keine
andere fahrerin nach ihr sie ist keine
18 jahre alt und feiert bereits ihren
ersten weltcupsieg
[Applaus]
mit ihr feiern ihre eltern mutter
gabriella
und vater pauli das risiko welches die
familie eingegangen ist beginnt sich
auszuzahlen mit fabienne suter wird eine
weitere schweizerinnen zweite doch wie
lara sich durchgesetzt hat macht den
cheftrainer sprachlos aber
heute wie sie gefahren ist direkt nach
23 nur gesagt diese zeit kann man nicht
sagen das war so ein perfektes laufe
nicht einfache situation verhält nicht
so dass ich sowie silly mit mit ihr
wissen man weiß nicht
ein jahr später sieht alles anders aus
zu hause in comano ist lara durch ihre
verletzung zum nichtstun verurteilt
das mache
[Musik]
auf dem sofa
antwortet dass die stunde von bessern
und das will ich schlafen
das ist so schnell vorbei sei es möglich
für das man muss ruhig und lieb probiere
schneller als jan dass sie will
alles schnell
gemacht ihr auch schnell verletzt aber
ich brauch mit sieht genau wie alle
lebten wir das mitte monat was für die
andere dinge für mich gesund da darf
erklärt geduldig glaube dass wir erst
ein einziges mal
am montag nach ihrem sieg in sankt
moritz lacht lara gut zum ersten mal vom
titelblatt der schweizer illustrierten
chefredaktor nik niethammer hat
kurzfristig umdisponiert und lara auf
die front gestellt
es hat sich überdurchschnittlich gut
verkauft sich eine vor der beste
verkäufer sie im 2008
zahlen möchte ich leider keine nennen
aber es ist ein überdurchschnittlich
gutes aussehen wie das jetzt
sicher der lara gut sz aber da hat es
einfach gepasst hätte man sie gewinnt
ihre erste weltcup rennen am samstag
aktuell moskau titelgeschichte mit ihre
mit einem strahlenden lachen sehr
sympathisch wenig die lara gut das ist
genau das was ich lese in baku tieren
allerdings vom beat material hier hat
das blatt welches sich seiner nähe zu
den stars rühmt einen kleinen abstand so
schnell
man auch hier nicht mit laras erfolg
gerechnet
sie ist jung sich sehr attraktiv sie
hätte in glamour faktor ihres lachen
ihre sehr markant die das
unkonventionelle wie sie trainiert wie
sie mit ihren ältere unterwegs ist das
ist natürlich schon mal eine eigene
geschichte für sie ja und dann hat sie
erfolg und das allein garantiert einer
chance großes in weiß schwarz live
nation ja ich bin vorsichtig mit dem mit
dem begriff nische besetzt sind erika
hess oder der andere ist sie hat sicher
das potenzial also mal zwei oder im
moment ist er noch das unbequemere die
dass jugendliche das seine ungestüme und
ich würde gern noch jedes mal mit einem
blieb wie dem markt sei die intimeren
bilder liefert die illustrierte schon
bald nach
[Musik]
weihnachten 2008 noch vor dem
jahreswechsel reist lara zum
riesenslalom nach simmering vater pauli
ist zu hause geblieben und schaut sich
das rennen am fernsehen an
die für das programm ab trotzdem ist
[Musik]
nach dem ersten lauf liegt lara an fünf
zehnter stelle doch im zweiten fährt sie
völlig entfesselt
dank überlegener bestzeit verbessert
sich lara gut noch auf den dritten
schlussrang
dass eltern ihre kinder während ihrer
sportkarriere betreuen dafür gibt es
viele beispiele die mut sind keine
ausnahme es ist ein weg nicht ohne
tücken das primärdefizit in krien luft
jagen beisteht und wenn du sie jetzt im
prinzip begleitet
unbedingt
[Musik]
wir sind zu dem punkt jetzt das beste
machen und dass beide auf beide sache
rücksichtnahme und das ist wichtig
natürlich was sie sportlich macht aber
es ist wichtig auch die beziehung bald
doch der mitteilte und ich war aber
jetzt wird sie immer interessanter und
desto mehr muss man muss man auf bosse
sie hat immer gesagt also noch am bein
hat sie mal gesagt also du papi du wirst
immer dabei sein die trainer vielleicht
wechseln wie andere leute die neben mir
sind weg sind und niemand kennt mich wie
du mich kennst und
sie sehen was gesagt ich brauche dich
auch schon jetzt dass er nicht
mitgegangen ist hat sie ja aber warum
kommst nicht mit nicht dass sie das eher
eine sicherheits punkt ist aber trotzdem
wenn sie etwas mit jemand sprechen will
sprich sie mit dem mit dem vater
durch den unfall ist plötzlich wieder
mutter gabriela zu laras bezugsperson
geworden
ich konnte nicht mehr programmieren und
meine sachen da mich nicht genervt aber
ich dachte ja du musst reagieren das hat
keinen sinn dass du wir wissen dass
jetzt so sehen das dass du nichts machen
kann also um versuche etwas zu machen
nicht einfach ich erfahre lassen das
bringt nicht das spendengeld
ich mach ziemlich viel abhängig von
diele von lagern
mögen sie zivile nutzung
besser
ich ja mit ihr
die die beziehung ist besser
kleinheit
war dieser herr februar 2009
weltmeisterschaften die fernsehzuschauer
lernen einen neuen aspekt von lara gut
kennen
[Musik]
lara die unbekümmerte die selbst ein wm
rennen nicht aus der ruhe bringt
halbe stunde vor show endspiel ganz
grund sind blieben ich verliere einfach
energie wir am start
damit muss man reden machen als die
natur an und denn wenn es losgeht dann
geht's los während andere fahrerinnen
sich schon stunden vor dem start nach
innen kehren sich konzentrieren und
unansprechbar sind stört lara gut noch
sekunden vor ihrem start mit ihrem
service mann und macht witze
[Gelächter]
konzentrier dich gut schaut voraus und
steht gut auf den außen china
hat seine versteckte kamera
[Musik]
als sie dies ein erstes mal machte war
ich schon etwas überrascht aber
alara braucht nur wenig zeit um sich zu
konzentrieren
zehn sekunden reichen hier
www nervös nein nie ich habe ihn nie
erlebt dass sie den druck eines rennens
gespürt hätte
meiner meinung nach macht genau die ist
ein unterschied zwischen einem star und
einem superstar
schon bei kompanie juni war dies so und
auch lara spürt die bedeutung eines
rennens nicht das ist extraklasse
erlebt
genau diese unbekümmertheit direkt lara
ihn war diese eher zum erfolg
und diese unbekümmertheit dieses
unerschütterliche selbstbewusstsein ist
lauras erfolgsgeheimnis dass sie zur
extraklasse markt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zwei medaillen gewinnt lara zweimal
silber in der abfahrt und in der
kombination
und dabei ist sie noch keine 18 jahre
alt
[Applaus]
für lara beginnt nach den rinnen ein
medien marathon alle reißen sich um sie
fernsehen radio zeitungen
dazwischen muss sie zur dopingkontrolle
sie findet kaum fünf minuten zeit für
sich selber sie hat keine ruhe und kaum
zeit zum essen ein happen zwischendurch
muss genügen
bis spät in die nacht hinein gibt lara
auskunft sie bleibt ruhig und freundlich
aber der rummel geht an die substanz
[Musik]
das kostet so muss die tour de www
handel und hoffentlich gut sitzt auf dem
sofa
[Applaus]
ich begrüße dass sich das ganze team
schon zeigen ihnen sei der vater baute
wurde gabriele psychotherapeutin service
mal alle sind da sind ein großes team
das wiener wohnen im geschäftlichen team
verkraftete
verrät ließ und
so was ist ihnen eigenen darum mit
helfer und die brems- oder die weiß
nicht was mit mir reden einfach zu einer
mit pdf wie die beste sicht auf das
brautpaar deinem verliehene folgen und
nicht umgekehrt und die geschäfte
[Musik]
die medaillen von val d' isere haben das
leben von lara gut einschneidend
verändert lara ist nicht mehr länger die
unbekümmerte junge tessinerin aus dem
kleinen com ahnung lara ist jetzt ein
star und ihr leben ein stück
allgemeingut
hanne bisher gearbeitet als
das immer gleiche aber nicht unbedingt
zeigen wo nigeria und was machte jungen
gelangen steinigung so dass das gehört
zu mir das waren jetzt zum beispiel auch
viele jahre 10
probleme mit dem reeder
der preis für den erfolg wie hier mit
ihrer cousine zara im tessin nur noch
spärlich in den ausgang gehen
wie sie das war dumm
und das ist
schön
[Musik]
alles läuft alles gut problemlos
und ab und zu hätten wir vielleicht auch
einige sachen unterschätzt und jetzt gab
zum beispiel auch zum training bat nach
lima mit wenn jetzt alle mit vorsicht
aber mit
[Musik]
mehr menschen bewusst
die stößt diese gehabt hatten die wie
sie die
hüftgelenk sinn
wenn sie ein zweites unfall könnte sein
kann also ich kann hier fertig macht und
da also sich zum erst ist richtig dass
sie die dort wieder ist dass die
muskulatur
wieder in ordnung ist bevor sie wieder
also rennen oder so
der sommer für skifahrerinnen ist kurz
schon im mai beginnt die vorbereitung
für den nächsten winter
ein fallschirmabsprung soll ablenkung
schaffen und gleichzeitig den umgang mit
der angst simulieren für lara ist es ein
neues erlebnis
doch dies macht sie in keiner weise
nervös
es geht los mit einem lehrer wird lara
aus 3000 meter einen tandemsprung wagen
vater pauli ist nur als zuschauer mit
dabei er wirkt angespannt
lara ist ruhig sie hat keine angst die
furchtlosigkeit ist neben der
unbekümmertheit laras zweite große
stärke ein weiteres puzzleteil ihres
erfolgsgeheimnisses
[Musik]
die
kurz vor laras landung ist auch vater
pauli mit dem flugzeug wieder unten und
spürbar erleichtert
die sie ich lebe
hast du angst um mich gehabt
weil ich mich
selber noch
mit dem fuß
nun wenn sie zu schnell laufen natürlich
für mädchen die komische situation sei
ganz so war und jetzt ist sie ja
eigentlich musik sprung aus dem flugzeug
ab und zwar in erster
linie ist eigentlich
war ja aber das ist normal
im moment hat sie
angst
vor
der angst vor dem motto daher kopf und
keiner sieht sportlich
aus meinen füßen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seit frühjahr 2009 darf lara gut auch
auf der straße gas geben kurz nach ihrem
18 geburtstag besteht sie die
fahrprüfung und die ek sponsor des
verbandes stellt die einen wagen zur
verfügung
aber nicht vergessen dass sie muss
zahlen und das ist auch nicht gerade das
will jetzt bin ich die einzige geld
einbringt in folge schaffen
denn also es kommt alles von mir habe
im olympia jahr absolviert lara gut das
sommertraining wiederum in der schweiz
den ganzen monat august wald sie hinzu
das team hat sich verändert mama
gabriella ist jetzt mit dabei dafür hat
mauro pini zum verband gewechselt
gabriela gut hat sich wie ihr mann ein
jahr zuvor als lehrerin beurlauben
lassen sie soll sich hauptsächlich um
die ausbildung von laras bruder jan
kümmern
[Applaus]
wir sind die ganze familie zusammen und
ich also wie sie die sind alle zu reden
die aufstieg ihrer tochter hat gabriela
im letzten jahr aus der ferne mit
verfolgt jetzt ist sie da mit dabei
ist reifer geworden also sie ist sich
auch gewachsen ein jahr mehr sie hat
diese diese neue situation erlebt für
das erste jahr und jetzt vielleicht hat
ja auch einige sachen begriffen wie sich
jetzt ändern musste und ja also siehst
mehr seriös in alle richtungen wenn du
sagst reifer geworden so zeigt sich dass
also auch mit die wisi punktuelle ist
manchmal also vorletztes jahr mussten
wir immer warten dass sie endlich fertig
war jetzt geben geben wir sie eine eine
uhr und sie ist pünktlich da müssen wir
nicht mehr als zuverlässig geworden ja
ja ja pauli gut hat nach dem abgang von
mauro pini wiederum die rolle des
trainers übernommen
pauli war schon früher laras trainer
damals als sie noch jugendrennen und im
europacup uhr
die einzig programm bringt es spezielles
gefühl da waren wir als hauptsponsor
für die musik nur ganz rechts nicht
gerade
einmal
richtig
aber das macht ja
bis jetzt
zum saisonabschluss fliegt lara gut im
frühjahr 2009 ein erstes mal nach
vancouver zusammen mit andrea dettling
[Musik]
denise feierabend und nadja kamer
besucht sie die olympia stadt
ms
die fünf skifahrerinnen hätten im
wm-winter die für die olympia selektion
erforderlichen resultate erzielt gehabt
argentinien singapur
[Gelächter]
die fünf fahrerinnen waren noch nie in
vancouver die idee des verbandes ist es
potenzielle olympia teilnehmerin schon
im voraus mit den lokalitäten vertraut
zu machen sie sollen sich schon etwas
auskennen falls sie ihn februar 2010
hierher zurückkommen würden selbst wenn
während olympia alles noch ein bisschen
größer und komplizierter sein wird
[Musik]
für die fünf fahrerinnen ist es eine
ideale annäherung an die olympia stadt
auch wenn nicht alle beim shopping
fündig werden
[Applaus]
315 tage dauerte es noch bis zur
eröffnung der spiele
logisch dass dann alle wieder hier sein
wollen
und es wird schon
zweieinhalb autostunden von vancouver
entfernt befindet sich das olympische
skigebiet von whistler von olympia und
dem damit verbundenen stress ist noch
nichts zu spüren
der traum von den spielen die
fahrerinnen wissen nun für was sie sich
einen sommer lang schinken werden
gerade die starre
denn ich glaube jetzt einstimmig den
kopf da und
denkt bestimmt und trauma
und so jetzt ist die beste und träume
schokofabrik glauben muss einfach
objektiv see und einfach mache was man
das kommt ganz anders
wegen ihrer verletzung wird es für lara
gut diesen winter keine olympischen
spiele geben
der arzt sofort also zwei drei monate
nach
januar januar heimat praktischer monat
vor olympia oder hätten
jetzt sehen der olympia-sechste wenn man
nicht 100 prozentig kritisch und sehr
wahrscheinlich rechts nicht für olympia
und
gesagt dass viele zu früh angefangen den
eingesetzten
wochen pause machen sei es wenig und
denn es geht und ja das reicht nicht und
fertig
[Musik]
keine olympischen spiele für lara gut in
diesem winter statt rennen zu fahren
muss lara mit ihrer physiotherapeutin in
mühsamer arbeit die stabilität die
residenz wieder aufbauen
es geht nur langsam voran große sprünge
gibt es keine geduld ist gefragt was
nicht die stärke von lara ist
das gefühl das ist normal dass sie das
kann auch das ebenso gewünscht dass sie
material das mache das
einfach mehr einfach mehr einfach
schneller sie und jetzt ich bin mir
sicher in zukunft
ihre die jede sekunde aus dass ich sage
dass wir meister
die meisten gefällt und
des gesunden
so wichtig ist wenn die
zuversichtswerte events zu spaßen das
war schlimm
das ist
das schon aber wenn ihr
diese kunde den kreisrat so schnell
verbesserte spring minute dann muss ich
nicht locker er will zurück um wieder
als fahrer wieder spaß und wieder
war die leistung bringen und wieder
machen was ich vorher gemacht haben und
vor eine nicht denkt 1 sekunden vorbei
sie
das stellen
wenn euch das drucker
den olympischen traum wie lara gut in
sotchi nachholen sie wird dann 22 jahre
alt sein und immer noch eine der
jüngsten
[Musik]